I could easily think about the past all
the time think about you know the medals
I've won the games I've won the highs the
lows chemo amputation but at the end of
the day like everything that happens
happens in the present so you just
got to keep moving forward my name is no
Grove and I play sled hockey for Team USA
Noah was born May 1st 1999 he was actually 3
weeks early as he got older and his red curly
hair and you know blue eyes can't help but fall
in love with him it's a lot of responsibility
because now you've brought this individual into
the world and you can't can't let him fail you
have to do everything you can to put your child in
the best situation so immediately the pressure and
the responsibility of being a father was [Music]
eminent he had a disease before he was diagnosed
with cancer he started showing some bruises on
his legs at 3 and a half years old and he's a
boy so of course he's going to have bruises
turned out he had ITP he had low platelets he
was probably um in and out of treatment for about
6 months and he was fine but then 6 months later
Noah had some heat in his left leg we took him to
his pediatrician and he ordered an x-ray and from
the X-ray he called us later that day or the next
morning and said I need you guys to go to Hopkins
tomorrow we went down there for the biopsy we
were first told that he had osteomylitis which
is a bone infection 24 hours later and it came
back as cancer I was like you got to be kidding
me it was in 2004 Noah was barely four or 4 and
a half years old he had a tumor in his left leg
it was osteosarcoma which is an aggressive bone
tumor that usually occurs in adolescence he was
one of the younger kids who had this cancer
he was a delightful young man he had a mop of
red hair on his head before he lost his hair to
chemotherapy chemotherapy is extremely difficult
I was sick every single day uh I couldn't eat I
couldn't even like brush my teeth that often if
I started bleeding through my gums or anything I
might bleed out I wouldn't be able to fight off
infections or anything like that his treatment
was a combination of surgery and chemotherapy
there there are two options that are usually
offered for the surgery they could either op
for an amputation or they could opt for what we
call a limb sparing surgery that means that they
put in artificial prosthesis it's a lengthening
prosthesis so automatically lengthens for a period
of time but because of his age he would need many
many surgeries for aevision I think that a lot of
surgeons and parents feel it's a sense of failure
to you know amputate [Music] so Rachel was on the
amputation team and I was on the save the leg team
after appointment where the doctor said it's his
leg or his life I guess I woke up at that moment
and said okay I get it now even when I think back
right now 19 and a half years down the road his
parents who were very young at at that time made
a very courageous decision we worked with the
social workers their suggestion was that we
tell him the night before my parents had explained
the whole situation and like you know your leg's
really sick um we need to take it off I really
don't know if he actually got it we did tell him
that uh his leg was going to go to heaven and you
know things like that so 5-year-old really doesn't
understand that I remember agreeing with them and
being like yeah this is like what we need to do um
but the second I got on you know on the operating
table I did not want to when he started crying
saying please don't take my leg I begged the
anesthesiologist to put him to sleep hurry [Music]
up waking up and the first thing I looked for was
my leg I mean mean like it sucked like you know
it it's not reversible this lion was given to
Noah by one of my very good friends he had this
with him during all of treatment the lion went
into the operating room with both legs just like
Noah did and when he woke up the lion was missing
his leg I'm considered a knee dis Arctic which is
an amputation through the knee having my entire
femur allowed me to I can weit bear all my weight
on it between physical therapy and getting him a
prosthesis you know he was trained to walk again
I played soccer basketball lacrosse baseball
you name it I played it you'd hear him running
down the field and it was click click click it
really didn't come as a difference with him and
his friends until he was about 12 or 13 that
20 lb prosthetic was slowing him down big time
and he couldn't keep up with the able-bodied
teammate so that's when he turned to slide
hackey at first I wasn't really into it but then
like I saw other kids trying it and it looked fun
so got and sled for the first time for the first
time he wasn't trying to keep up he was set in the
pace I fell up hocky the speed the skill the
physicality I mean hockey's got everything that
you want in a sport carry carry carry carry
hey you got drum you got drum in 2014 I had
actually watched the team win golden SOI I knew
that right then and there I wanted to be on the
national team hey download download down they
have a development Camp every single summer he
Changs coming up 2 and 1/2 years out at that point
that was the year that I got my driver's license
and so every day after school drive right to the
rink and then head right to the gym after the next
year comes around and Coach like to me for the
national team rest of his history he's won quite
a few World Championships so that's what these
are in 2019 he won player of the game in a world
championship and then these are his gold medals
this is from 2018 and payon Chang and then Beijing
[Music] 2022 watching him on the ice is a lot
of fun whether it be for USA or even for his
club team take a shot Take a Shot Hockey
taught me a lot of life lessons hard work
dedication perseverance yeah yeah yeah yes sir
it's really challenged me to be a better version
of myself and that's kind of just been my goal
throughout my entire hockey career is to be as
good as I could be at hockey good game boys
hey good work I think Noah affects a ton of
people that he would never even imagine when
I get a new patient with a similar cancer but
wants to look ahead and see the light again you
can talk about Noah he is probably one of the
most inspiring kids I wouldn't change what we did
because I still have him you know so there's many
parents who can't say something when I
was diagnosed there were several other
kids who were also diagnosed with
similar forms of Cancer all of them
had had the option to amputate and um
they didn't and none of them are living
today recently I was able to celebrate my
19 years off cancer treatment I'm entirely
grateful for the rest of my life for the decision
that my parents made I found a purpose in sled
hockey don't know where I would be today without
[Music]
it